Speaker 1: And while we're on the subject of guns,
we obviously have a big one this week, the
United States Supreme Court, in addition
to curtailing Miranda rights here in the United
States, saying that you can no longer sue police
officers for violating your Miranda rights,
which basically means they don't exist anymore.
They also issued a 6 to 3 ruling along party
lines, which is how every ruling is going to be, I
guess, from now on. Striking down a New York state
concealed carry law. And here's what this law did.
This law said that you could only get a
concealed carry permit in the state of New
York if you were able to show a need to have
a concealed gun on you at all times. Well,
gun rights advocates sued. It's legislation,
by the way, has been in place for decades upon
decades upon decades, I think almost 100 years.
And the Supreme Court says, you know what,
your right. There are no limits on the Second
Amendment. So you can't tell people that they
have to have a reason to need a concealed carry
permit. Nope. Let's take it back to the wild,
wild west. Which the wild, wild west, by the way,
technically wasn't even like that. They actually
had strict gun control laws. Just an expression
that we use too many times. I do as well.
That really isn't even rooted in reality. But
that's what the Supreme Court said this week.
Here's the thing. Most states allow for concealed
carry. The issue is you have to have the permit.
And, of course, the Supreme Court, in
their majority opinion, did say we're
not taking away the permit requirements. All
we're doing is taking away the requirement.
For people who can even apply for a permit. So
initially, obviously, when this ruling came down,
a lot of I don't want to call it overreaction
because we don't want more guns in the streets.
More guns statistically means more death. We
know that that is the truth, but. It's not quite
as devastating, I think, as everybody is
kind of portraying it to be. Because, again,
New York State can still say, okay, you have
to have a concealed carry permit. We have to
know everybody that is walking around carrying a
gun. You have to apply for it. You have to pass
the background checks, the fingerprint checks. You
have to, you know, make it past the red flag laws.
If you do all of that. Then you can have your
concealed carry. And even the conservatives on the
Supreme Court said, that's okay. We're not taking
that away. So I guess I guess that's a positive.
I guess it's not as horrible. But
it's still pretty frickin horrible.
But this is what they do. This is what this
extremist right wing Supreme Court does. No more
Miranda rights. No more Roe. And guns everywhere.
That's the United States of America in 2022.